es esta película La noche del 12 la que
se robó el show en la ceremonia número
48 de los premios César
en la versión francesa de los Oscar el
filme ganó el galardón a mejor película
y mejor director
basada en una historia real la película
trata sobre un feminicidio una joven
quemada
en la sociedad
todo el movimiento nos hace
necesariamente más atentos y más
sensibles a estas cuestiones no estoy
seguro de que hubiéramos hecho la misma
película hace 10 años
no queríamos hacer una película con una
agenda sino cuestionar ciertas cosas
queríamos Escuchar lo que las mujeres
tienen que decir sobre esta violencia la
elección de la academia como mejor
película es significativa los César han
sido objeto de reiteradas críticas por
sexismo
hace tres años fue cuestionada por
conceder el premio de la mejor dirección
a Román Polanski condenado por violación
y prófugo de la justicia estadounidense
en los últimos 23 años desde que en 2000
Tony Marshall ganara por Venus Beauty
institute ninguna mujer ha ganado El
César a la mejor dirección
a pesar de que las mujeres francesas
exigen igualdad y ganan los máximos
galardones en los festivales de can
Berlín y Venecia este año no hubo
ninguna mujer nominada en los César para
el premio
los galardones a mejor actor y mejor
actriz fueron concedidos a avenua
Maribel por su película pacificación y
Virginia por recuerdos de París